[Music]
can you guess what you're looking at is
it a fuzzy sock an overripe banana a
moldy tube of toothpaste in fact this is
the humble sea cucumber and while it
might look odd its daily toil paved the
way for entire ecosystems to thrive sea
cucumbers are members of the phylum
echinodermata along with sea urchins
starfish and other radially symmetrical
spiny skinned marine invertebrates some
sea cucumbers have feathery tentacles
flowing from their mouths some are
puffed like bloated balloons and others
simply look like headless chicken
monsters the actual name given to a rare
deep-sea species but they are generally
characterized by their long cylindrical
shape a sea cucumber
is essentially a brainless fleshy form
surrounding a digestive tract bookended
by a mouth and an anus adhesive tube
feet run the length of their bodies and
allow them to scooped along the sea
floor specialised tube feet can be used
for feeding and respiration there many
sea cucumbers actually breathe through
their anuses rhythmically contracting
and relaxing their muscles they draw
water in and out over an internal lung
like structure called a respiratory tree
that extracts oxygen from seawater
certain species of crabs and pearl fish
take advantage of this rhythmic action
and once the sea cucumbers anus is
dilated they shimmy in and take shelter
the rear end of a single sea cucumber
can Harbor up to 15 pearl fish at a time
however it seems that not all sea
cucumbers put up with this intrusive
behavior some species are equipped with
five teeth around their anus suggesting
that they may have taken an evolutionary
stand against unwanted guests
but even see who covers that lack anal
teeth are outfitted with tools to defend
themselves they evade threats and launch
counter-attacks using their mutable
collagenous tissue or mc2
this gel like tissue contains bundles of
collagen called fibrous proteins can
interact with these fibrils to slide
them together stiffening the tissue or
apart softening it
this versatile tissue has many
advantages it aids an efficient
locomotion enables CP plumbers to fit
into small spaces and allows them to
reproduce asexually by splitting apart
but MC T is most explosive application
is employed when a predator attacks by
loosening the attachments of internal
tissues and quickly softening and
contracting their muscles many species
are capable of shooting a wide range of
organs out of their anuses this act is
called evisceration and it's a
surprisingly effective defense mechanism
in addition to startling and distracting
predators the innards of some sea
cucumber species are sticky and toxic
evisceration may seem drastic but sea
cucumbers are able to regenerate what
they've lost to their gut reaction in
just a few weeks time aside from the few
species that are evolved to swim and
those that feed without moving many of
these cumbersome creatures past their
time grazing the seabed sea cucumbers
are found everywhere from shallow shores
to abyssal trenches 6000 metres below
sea level on the deep sea floor they
comprised the majority of animal biomass
reaching up to 95% in some areas as
these sausage shaped wonders trudged
along they vacuumed up sand digests the
organic matter it contains and excrete
the byproduct in this process sea
cucumbers clean and oxygenate the sea
floor by breaking down detritus and
recycling nutrients this creates the
conditions for seagrass beds and
shellfish to thrive sea cucumber
excretions can also aid in coral
formation and may play a role in
buffering marine environments from ocean
acidification as the ocean's vacuum
cleaners they are very good at their job
about half of the sandy sea floor is
thought to have passed through the
digestive tract of Asik
number so next time your rejoicing in
the feeling of sand
crunching between your toes consider
this those very grains of sand might
have at one point or another been
excreted by a pickup that breathes
through its butt if you're looking for
more strange creatures who call this
planet home don't miss this video about
naked mole-rats
cold-blooded mammals with the metabolism
of plants or perhaps you'd like to know
more about the octopus whose entire body
is a brain
[Music]